sometimes even actors decide they've had
enough although it's probably fair to
say that their bad days are a lot more
dramatic than anyone else's While most
walk-offs result from a tough day on set
or some disagreement with the crew a few
stars have been calling it a day for
much nobler reasons Big Bang Theory and
call me cat actor Mayan beik Departed
the set of her other job as host of
Jeopardy in May of 2023 however her walk
out wasn't spurred by any personal beef
with the show rather beik left the long
running game show to stand in solidarity
with the ongoing strike by the The
Writers Guild of America Jeopardy
champion Ken Jennings who altered
hosting duties with beik took over bik's
role as host for Celebrity Jeopardy and
other episodes for the final week of its
39th season B Alex gesture was echoed a
month later by scream Sick Star dermit
morron who walked off the set of the
view in June while promoting the Disney
plus series secret Invasion the actor
was participating in a pre-taped
interview for the daytime talk series
when he announced to the host that he
would be walking off to support the
Striking riters thank you I'll see you
on the pick lines
in in a statement issued after the
taping said I find it incredibly
important to continue to support the
union Liam Michelle wasn't always on the
best of terms with her Glee co-stars but
one specific incident with the late Nia
Rivera led her to storm off the set of
the hit series on April 17th 2014 TMZ
reported that according to sources close
to Rivera Michelle's so-called Diva
Antics had recently annoyed most of the
casting crew on set apparently she made
everyone wait to shoot a scene while she
dealt with personal matters Rivera
finally went to the producers and warned
them that Michelle was beginning to
annoy people and when Michelle learned
about that she left the set sources
close to Michelle played down the story
telling TMZ that the actor wasn't aware
of any complaints about her and wasn't
even shooting scenes with Rivera at the
time additional rumors suggest that
Rivera was the one who got thrown off
set in 2016 Rivera published a book in
which she admitted that she and Michelle
did not get along she wrote Leah and I
were like two sides of the same battery
we were both strong willed in
competitive not just with each other but
with everyone and that's not a good
mixture the fight between Carl weather's
AP Creed and Dolph lungren Ivan Drago
and Rocky 4 is truly brutal and what
went down behind the scenes was nearly
as bad according to Sylvester Stallone
weathers and lungren did not get along
on set when the two were in the ring
lungren had been too aggressive with
weathers causing weathers to storm
offset while yelling profanities at his
co-star after 4 days during which
production on the movie stalled Stallone
finally convinced weathers to return but
only if lungren agreed to go easier in
the ring in 2020 Yahoo entertainment
spoke with lungren about his onset prus
with Weathers lren said I was a fighter
a karate champion from Europe and I
think when Carl showed up he was like
I'm going to have to fight this guy he
seems like he's the real thing I didn't
dislike anybody on that set but I think
he got a little scared of me then I had
to kill him of course lungren is
probably referring to what his character
had to do in the movie there but in
retrospect maybe weathers was smart to
get out of there 1971's a French
Connection is considered one of the
greatest movies ever made but onset
difficulties between Jean Hackman and
legendarily two-fisted director William
friedkin almost killed the film Al
together speaking with Christopher mcy
in 2016 fredkin explained that Hackman
had grown up with a distaste for
authority and as the authority figure on
set fredkin needed to make Hackman angry
fredkin would tell the actor pal you
better get a day job you know you you
better look for something else cuz this
isn't working out and he actually quit
the film according to fredkin it took an
intervention from Hackman's agent Sue
MERS to bring the actor back to set she
apparently said you know you will own
everything they've spent so Jean stuck
around and stuck it out of course if he
had dropped out of the movie Hackman
would have missed an Oscar for best lead
actor you've got to Hope Sue got a raise
for that one pay dunway has long held a
reputation for being difficult to work
with but she's not to blame for the
incident between her and Roman blany on
the set of the 1974 classic Chinatown at
one point the director apparently
plucked a hair from dunaway's head
causing her to scream profanities at him
before storming offset in 2009 interview
magazine asked bansky if he ever talked
to dunway after filming Chinatown
blansky who has since been disgraced for
committing a Litany of sex crime said oh
yeah of course last time I saw her was
in can last year she was also giving a
prize we met in the bathroom I was
washing my hands and some woman was
washing her hands and she said hi Roman
I look up in the mirror and it was Fay
and that apparently was that Ridley
Scott's critically acclaimed historical
drama Gladiator received several Academy
Awards including best picture and best
lead actor for Russell Crow but the film
star didn't make that Journey
particularly easy when Gladiator was
released in 2000 Time Magazine published
an article about the making of the movie
the article claimed that Crow had doubts
about the ever evolving script and at
one point stormed off the set when he
didn't get the answers he demanded a
DreamWorks executive told the magazine
Russell was not well behaved he tried to
rewrite the entire script on the spot he
did a lot of posturing and put the fear
of God into some people thankfully
Ridley never yelled he was the voice of
reason dealing with many unreasonable
factors not the least of which was his
lead 20 years later Gladiator producer
Douglas Wick told Cinema Blend that
reported reports of Crow's heavy
involvement in the script were greatly
exaggerated adding Russell constantly
had a strong point of view of what
Maximus would do and not do but there
wasn't much improvisation comedy Legend
Chevy Chase played outlandish
millionaire Pierce Hawthorne in the cult
sitcom community in the years since his
bitter Feud with series Creator Dan
Harmon has become the stuff of legend
that when he walks into the room the
temperature changes I mean he he's
unignorable according to a deadline
piece published in March 2012 Chase
walked off the set on the last day of
shooting for C 3 a decision that sparked
his conflict with Harmon the following
August Harmon shed some light on why
Chase stormed off set and one of reddits
asked me anything sessions writer
producer Adam County had apparently
pitched the tag for the finale which
would have served as an emotional
epilogue for the third season Chase
however refused to shoot the scene
because he didn't think it was funny
whenever the actor walked off the set
before that the crew simply picked up
his shots later in the week but since
they were filming the season finale the
sets came down after Chase went home the
scene was never shot and Harmon was
understandably not happy about about it
Chase left the show later that year the
2019 sci-fi flick at Astra C Brad Pit is
an emotionally distant astronaut
searching for his long lost father and
the actor may have endured his own
family struggles behind the scenes in
2017 Hollywood Life reported that pit
was stressed out over his divorce with
Angelina Jolie claiming he had stormed
off the set while shooting a difficult
scene a source claimed that pit who was
attached to wires at the time had
previously engaged in heated discussions
with director James Gray before then
these discussions apparently hadn't hurt
the production at all Hollywood life's
Insider added that pit is not a bad guy
and suggested that his emotions simply
got the best of him that day they said
he has been living very clean and has
not been drinking smoking or vaping and
that has been challenging for Brad too
yesterday all that tension came to a
head and things kind of got out of hand
Dame Diana rig received much Acclaim for
her portrayal of the quick wited lady
olena Tyrell on the Blockbuster Series
Game of Thrones and while she did walk
off the set at one point during filming
she didn't do it out of spite in 2020
rig's co-star Jessica henwick told
Entertainment Weekly how rig had taken a
curious shortcut to perform a brief
scene in season 6 henwick said she
walked onto the set and went I'm ready
now a cameraman came over and went well
okay but we haven't finished setting up
she interrupted him and said roll the
cameras and she just started doing her
lines she did two takes and then the guy
came over and was like great now we're
going to do a closeup and she just stood
up and she went I'm done and Wick added
that rig couldn't walk particularly
quickly at the time meaning the entire
cast and crew had to watch as she
stormed off the set in slow motion
henwick said she cracked me up I loved
her Wen Phoenix has earned something of
a reputation for his committed
performances in critically acclaimed
films such as walk the line and the
master and it appears that his ability
to immerse himself in the minds of his
characters can on occasion be too much
to bear you wouldn't get it case in
point his Oscar winning turn in Joker
which spurned Phoenix to walk off set
during filming on several scenes in a
profile of Phoenix for the New York
Times Joker director Todd Phillips
explained that the actor often startled
his co-stars with with his abrupt exits
he said the poor other actor thinks it's
them and it was never them it was always
him and he just wasn't feeling it but as
a filmmaker noted Phoenix always used
his exits to regain his Focus recalling
that the actor once told him we'll take
a walk and we'll come back and do it
Phoenix's Joker co-star Robert dairo who
was no stranger to intense performances
himself understood Phoenix's need to
exit he said Wen was very intense in
what he was doing as it should be as he
should be there's nothing to talk about
personally on the side let's have coffee
let's just do this stuff in 2021
Jennifer Aniston joined her friends
co-stars on the HBO special friends the
reunion and she was surprised that the
event proved so emotional afterwards she
told The Hollywood Reporter I think we
were just so naive walking into it
thinking how fun is this going to be
then you get there and it's like oh
right I hadn't thought about what was
going on the last time I was actually
here Aniston told the publication that
on several occasions a collision of past
and present forced her to walk off set
in order to regain her composure the
emotional flood came from a kind of 2020
hindsight Aniston and her co-star were
immediately reminded of where they were
in their lives when the show ended in
2004 and where they would go in the
years that followed Aniston said it was
like high past remember me remember how
that sucked it was all very jarring and
of course you've got cameras everywhere
and I'm already a little emotionally
accessible I guess you could say so I
had to walk out at certain points Alec
Baldwin found himself at the heart of
the media tension surrounding the
shooting death of cinematographer helina
Hutchins during filming on the movie
rust but another name was frequently
featured in coverage Hannah gutier Reed
who as the film armorer was in charge of
overseeing the prop weapons including
the gun that killed Hutchin I'm the
armor or at least I was according to the
rap gutier Reed previously ran into
trouble as an armorer on another Western
the old way where her apparent
inexperience reportedly compelled
Nicholas Cage to walk off the set the
outlets feature quoted Stu brumall a key
grip on the old way who said that guti's
Reed was so inexperienced at her job
that she fired live ammunition near cast
and crew on two occasions during the
shoot this reportedly angered cage who
before stor forming off set yelled make
an announcement you just blew my
eardrums out however a producer of the
old way told the rap that they had no
recollection of such an event during
filming they insisted the details on
some of these accounts specifically when
it pertains to the old way have been
blown out of proportion Patrick
Stewart's transition from British stage
and TV actor to a Hollywood star State
side was not without its Rocky moments
in a 1994 interview with TV Guide Stuart
acknowledged that the long hours and
emotional challenge of playing Jean Luke
peard on Star Trek the Next Generation
occasionally led to tense moments he
said it just became overwhelming I did
my fair quota of yelling that's true at
one point Stuart walked off during a set
visit by Good Morning America which
Stuart perceived as demeaning he said I
thought that it was disrespectful they
were doing stick in our costumes and I
thought it was demeaning to the show I'm
at my least diplomatic when there's a
lack of respect and I'm not speaking
only of me but when I see anyone or any
group of people being treated
disrespectfully that's when I'm inclined
to lose it among the many celebrities
who face the Apocalypse in the 2013
comedy this is the end was Harry Potter
star Emma Watson who in one scene was to
battle of cannibalistic Danny McBride
leading Channing Tatum on a leash
hardcore man rumors have swirled for
years that Watson walked off the set
because of the scene's content in an
interview with British GQ Seth Rogan
attempted to set the record straight he
said I think sometimes when you read
something when it comes to life it
doesn't seem to be what you thought it
was but it was not some terrible ending
to our relationship Rogan added that
Watson not only came back the next day
but also helped to promote the film of
her decision to leave the that he said
she was probably right Rogan later
doubled down on the issue on his Twitter
account where he wrote that the popular
story didn't portray the event
accurately most notably he claimed
Watson did not storm off the set as was
frequently reported Rogan tweeted scene
was not what was originally scripted was
getting improvised changed drastically
and was not what she agreed to I'm very
sorry and disappointed it happened and I
wish I had done more to prevent it what
happens when two notorious tough guys
Clash over a movie in the case of
accidental love the answer is they both
abandoned the project hard case number
one James Khan who walked off the set
after director David O Russell asked him
to both cough and choke during a scene
in which his character a US senator
affixiated on a cookie KH quit the film
and his role was recast with James
Brolin the other immovable object was of
course Russell who had a long history of
butting heads with his actors literally
and figuratively accidental love endured
a troubled production from its start in
2008 due largely to budgetary problems
that caused numerous shutdowns as well
as difficulties stemming from Russell's
own temperament after 2 years of such
issues Russell abandoned the film in
2010 it was eventually released to a
chor of negative reviews though he
eventually redeemed his career to a
degree with CSI Miami David Caruso
initially halted his own rise to startom
and NYPD Blue by walking away from the
show after one season Caruso earned an
Emmy nomination for his turn on the
controversial cop drama but also found
himself the emnity of series co-creators
Steven botko and David milge due to his
volatile behavior on set in his 2016
Memoir bachko wrote Caruso's Behavior
was simply put cancerous kuso reportedly
wanted to leave the series to work in
movies and bachko eventually broke her
to deal whereby the actor could filmed
the first four episodes of Blue's second
season so he could be properly written
out of the show you transferred to
burough dispatch sty John steady Day
Tour effective tomorrow after filming
his final scene Caruso reportedly walked
off sets and never looked back bko wrote
when he had shot his last scene of the
fourth episode he turned without a word
and left the set the stage and the lot
he didn't say a single word of thanks or
goodbye to his castmates nothing now
that the 80s cult comedy Al is being
revived by Ryan Reynolds Studio it's
perhaps time to recognize that the
original series was no picnic for the
cas and crew the show which ran on NBC
from 1986 to 1990 featured a cast of
actors interacting with the title
creature an eccentric alien portrayed by
a puppet operated by series co-creator
Paul Fusco to accommodate the 43-in
puppet The Sound Stage was built off the
ground and riddled with poles through
which Fusco manipulated the puppet this
arrangement required long hours which
were exacerbated by the fact that Alf
was the star of the series and the
humans were his second bananas actor Max
Wright who played family patriarch
Willie Tanner later said it was hard
work and very Grim actor an shadine who
played Wily's wife Kate told People
magazine that right's frustrations with
the series came to a head during the
filming of its final episode she
explained there was one take and Max
walked off the set went to his dressing
room got his bags went to his car and
disappeared nobody had to say rap and
there were no goodbyes R had a change of
heart about his co-star sometime before
his death in 2019 however as he said it
doesn't matter what I felt or what the
days were like Al brought people a lot
of Joy the Walt Disney company's bitter
war of words with Florida Governor Ronda
Santa spur a walk out by employees in
2022 is part of protest against a
controversial State education Bill actor
Raven Simone a member of the lgbtq plus
community and star of the Disney Channel
series Raven's home participated in the
protest alongside her co-stars they
walked off the series set to De cry
House Bill 1557 a notorious don't say
gay bill which prohibits discussion of
sexual orientation or gender identity in
early years classrooms that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students the actor
posted a video with her castmates on her
Instagram account that solidified her
stance on the bill the caption read in
today's world it is imperative that we
take stands show support and move
forward not backwards every family every
person and every child deserves to be
recognized no matter their race gender
or sexual orientation employees from
many Disney companies including Marvel
Studios Lucas film and 20th Century Fox
also participated in the protest the
1967 James Bond spoof Casino Royale was
a convoluted project to begin with
featuring a vast International cast and
using up no fewer than five directors
Before Peter s's complicated matters
almost Beyond
repair James I need you yes yes yes well
I can understand that my dear I can
understand that cast is a bakarat champ
hired by James Bond to impersonate him
during the game the actor was plagued by
mood swings and insecurities throughout
the shoot he fought both verbally and
physically with longtime friend and
collaborator Joe McGrath and he also
refused to appear in scenes opposite
Orson Wells which required them to be
shot at separate times eventually
sellers walked off the film altogether
forcing producer Charles Feldman to
scramble in order to save the picture
from collapse the solution was to
rewrite the script so that half of the
movie's characters also impersonated Bon
the ruse didn't really help win over
critics but audiences were apparently
delighted with the high Jinks Casino
Royale ended up being one of the most
profitable films of 1967
according to the legendary director
verer Herzog actor Claus kinsky walked
out on 35 films in 5 years and while
making a GE a the wrath of God it
appeared for a brief time that he was
going to abandon his 36th feature but in
an interview with Roger eert in 2005
Herzog said that he not only stood up to
the notoriously combustive kinsky but he
did so in an entirely hertzog esque way
kinsky Breaking Point reportedly came at
the end of the difficult shoot which
took place in the Peruvian rainforest
and frequently forced the cast to float
down the Amazon and rafts at one point
kinsky lost his temper after seeing a
set photographer smile while he was
performing in a scene and demanded that
Herzog dismissed them when the director
bulked kinsky gathered his belongings
and climbed into a speedboat for a
dramatic departure in his interview with
Ebert the director debunked rumors that
he forced kinsky to acted gunpoint and
said that his words were enough to Halt
the actor's Rampage he remembered I said
to him I do have a rifle he could try to
take the boat and he might reach the
next Bend of the river but he would have
eight bullets through his head after
realizing that the director was serious
and happy kinsky returned to complete
the film which is today regarded as one
of herzog's greatest Productions Fox's
reality competition series The Mast
singer pred itself on its light-hearted
tongue and cheek tone but the revelation
of one contestant sparked an
uncomfortably serious moment during
episode 7 of its sth season in 2022 in
the episode the mass celebrity hammering
his way through a tonee rendition of Bad
to the Bone was revealed to be Rudy
Giuliani as you're probably well aware
the former New York mayor and Lawyers
Association with former president Donald
Trump has resulted in the decline of his
professional career including multiple
indictments for his alleged
participation in a conspiracy to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
and they're going to they're going to
they're going to degrade themselves by
doing a mug shot of me like people won
recognize me when Giuliani was revealed
inside the Jack in the Box costume three
of the judges Jenny McCarthy Wahlberg
Nicole Scherzinger and Robin Thick
responded with various degrees of
surprise where the fort judge Ken Jong
responded with stone-faced silence and
crossed his arms until Julia y reprised
the song at that point Jung said he was
done and exited the set dick also left
the set though his departure was not
shown on camera Rob Wade Fox
entertainment's president of alternative
entertainment and specials stood by the
casting after the episode aired Adam
Sandler's critically reviled comedy the
ridiculous 6 found himself in trouble
when reports surfaced that several
indigenous American actors had walked
off the set in 2015 reportedly they were
protesting what they perceived as
racially insensitive jokes and
disrespectful treatment by The film's
Producers the Indian country today media
Network reported that a dozen actors
walked out after speaking to unnamed
producers Lauren Anthony one of the
actors involved said they just treated
us as if we should just be on the side
film student Allison young who also left
the set said that producers labeled them
as oversensitive at the time she said we
talked to the producers about our
concerns they just told us if you guys
are so sensitive you should leave
however the New York daily news quoted
Native American actor Ricky Lee who said
that only four actors left the set while
many others remained Lee said believe me
if everyone was really offended there
would be a much bigger uproar he also
noted that Sandler spoke to several
indigenous American actors about the
walkouts before the film's rap party Lee
claimed the last thing that he said
before he got up was that the thing that
made him feel the worst is that poor
people got their feelings
hurt